we are very very fortunate to have a
holocaust survivor
hannah lewis here in the studio good
morning good morning and it is a
privilege to have you here hannah if you
don't mind me saying because
this is a part of our history that a lot
of people
my age and younger are becoming less and
less familiar with and i think we do
need to
become more aware about what happened to
stop it happening again
so can you tell us what your situation
was
how you got caught up in the labor camps
well i was born in a very small town
called whatever on the court
on the borders of the river bog and i
think
that probably the camps came quite late
to us
my family were very established there
and
very happy and quite well known quite
well to do
i think we were probably rounded up
at first it became a ghetto because more
and more refugees from big cities
wanted to find comparative safety so
at that point our house began to fill up
with
other with other jews looking for
somewhere
somewhere to live and a ghetto was
formed and i actually have photos of my
grandfather
and my uncle in the ghetto
we were rounded up i think it must have
been
1943 and
we walked to a camp a fourth labour camp
called
adam pol which was probably if you can
call it lucky
luckier than being sent to sobibor i was
actually born very close to savvy boar
and if you were sent to savvyboy you had
a very short
very short term two days at the most to
survive hannah how old were you
at that point i was born 37 so i must
have been
43 uh six seven do you remember that
walk
i do i remember that walk very well i
remember that the weather was nice
and i remember that when i got tired
either my mother
or my aunt or my father somebody carried
me part of the way
we actually were rounded up as a family
and we ended up in a forced labour camp
in a small village called adampo
and i've been back there twice since
because i just wanted to make sure that
what i remembered
i actually remembered and it's
not very much changed at the time that
we were there
there was no electricity and there was
no running water
because i remember my mother when she
was working
having to carry big buckets of water
umpteen times a day
because you know you use a lot of water
you don't realize how much we use
and so what happened in the camp itself
and what happened to you
in the camp itself my grandfather was
killed in the first einzatz group
my father eventually
managed to escape with his cousin and
joined the partisans which was good
my mother was allocated
to work for a very
old well he seemed old to me i always
remember him as stari pan which means
old man
he was somebody that my grandfather and
my father knew
because my parents had
a big shop in voidava and they owned
properties
and they owned the flour mill the
sawmill so they knew a lot of polish
people because
in the villages or townships because
they were either milling their flower or
doing something for them so they knew
them and when my grandfather heard
because there was no escape that there
was going to be a work camp there
or nobody really knew what a forced
labor camp was
he and my father went to see this old
man who was
purported to be the sort of go-between
between the
germans and the and and the
population and asked him
he gave him whatever he could and asked
him
not for himself he didn't know where we
would be sent
but if we were sent there would he do
his best
to protect his two
grandchildren i had one little cousin
who was born deaf and mute
and the old man did his best i don't
think he had any power but i think
probably in
fif by 43 i think the war wasn't going
quite as smoothly as they would have
liked
and he um
he was an old bachelor he had a
his niece and her family helping him run
the farm which was
sort of his biggest farm and my mother
and i were allotted
to work for him we still slept in the
camp
and what i can only describe as sheds
with drawers you sort of laid and
but all of that actually was okay as
long as i was with my mother
and it was brutal so it was just you and
your mum at that time together
well only yes in the all the men
for some reason had either escaped or
been or been killed
and what happened in terms of did your
mother survive the camp
my mother survived to almost the end
she was very always very calm and very
capable
but towards the end of the war we didn't
know was the end of the war
i got typhus i think i mean typhus was
right
because there was absolutely no hygiene
or doctors and my mother asked if we
might spend
one night in the kitchen because
there was a big oven which gave heat
and we were we were allowed
we were we were allowed by the over the
the old man's
um yeast to do this so my mother made up
the bed
and it was very very cold
and we settled down for the night
and i was restless and she was restless
and sometime during the night
there was a little tap tap on the back
door window
and my mother sat up and listened and it
happened
again so she went to the window and it
was so
frosty that she couldn't she couldn't
wipe it
so she opened the little window and
there on the doorstep
was my father who as i said had escaped
and joined the partisans
and one of the things that partisans did
would be to warn
camps if they could or get a message
that there was going to be a nines
that's grouping
and that's what he was doing can you
just explain what that is
and einsatzgruppen were
elite squads who would go to places
and do executions so they would line
people
up they'd line you up by
whatever they wanted you to and
the horror of that is is
we know it happened i get the horror is
still very
very hard to perceive
how important is it
that we hear not only your story but
also look back in the the the films and
the textbooks and the the
museums that there are and what have you
to actually
understand this what happened that this
was
human beings acting against human beings
for no good reason well to make sure
that this
does not cannot happen again
i think what happened was an
extraordinary crime
because the jews weren't at war with
hitler
i think that the cold-blooded
extermination of a
whole section of community was awful
i think it has to be education i think
i mean i'm very involved with the
holocaust educational trust
and i go into schools and universities
and
banks and all sorts of places and
sometimes i'm quite taken aback
at how little knowledge they have
so if it is it is short in schools now
but i think it's very difficult in
three sessions or four sessions to get
what led up to it what happened and the
awful atrocities was your mother then
taken away about that no well what
happened is they were having this
there was this roundup and
my father said to my mother that she
should come with him
and my mother said no panic was not well
and he said bring her with and she said
she won't make it and whether it was the
searchlight or whether it was a patrol
or whatever my father obviously
disappeared
and my mother would die just stay there
and very early in the morning
there were the usual sounds there are
sounds that are
somehow relevant with what they did
and we just laid there and then
i don't know how long this was but there
was a whack on the door
and my mother who was very calm always
got on her knees gave me a huge hug
and a kiss and then very calmly
without hurrying went to the door
opened it and closed it behind her
and i just waited for her to come back i
thought
she was bound to come back but the noise
continued and she didn't come back
so i opened the door and i stood in the
steps and i saw them
marshalling them all to this well that
she
always drew water from and
we always made contact eye contact but
we didn't this particular time
and i was just deciding whether i should
go and take a hand
when somebody barked out an order they
were all lined up by the well
and they started to shoot and i saw her
fall
and i saw the blood on the snow and i
knew that one moment
why she wasn't looking and i knew i
could not
i could i could not scream or do
anything
so then i went back and put myself
on this pellet and somehow survived the
war
and after the war
we weren't ever actually liberated we
were just left alone
and nobody knew what was happening and
nobody came for me
how old were you at this at this point
it was 45 so must have been eight
but you were left completely alone in
that labour camp yes
and yes but there were people and people
were
kind i mean you know people not
haven't lost all their sensitivity um
and then one day my father appeared
he had walked from i don't know where
he was dirty and skinny but it was my
father
and so another part of our life started
we left adam pole
we went back to foreign where i was born
my father and my grandfather had
obviously
foreseen what was happening because he
dug up suitcases which
held family albums and and artifacts
and we eventually made our way to woods
and in 1949 i came to
england on my own without my father
to live with his aunt and uncle
can i ask you just to finish
how you've how have you managed to to
move on i mean obviously you're doing a
tremendous amount of educational work on
a subject which is
in incredibly um
hurtful and and sad for you
are you able to do that without
bitterness
looking is there a benefit to
almost a sense of forgiveness i know
it's a very difficult word in a way but
it's
do you just do you understand what i
mean i know what you're saying
are you asking me do i forgive
yes in a way okay well
i don't know that i have forgiveness
i don't think i'm empowered to forgive
for the people
who were tortured and killed i don't
speak for them
and for myself i don't know
that i have forgiveness but i have
acceptance
i can't change it hannah it
it is quite something to talk to you and
it is
very very important to hear your story i
think and i hope that it will resonate
with people actually as we remember all
that happened
in the holocaust thank you very much
indeed for talking thank you thank you